lining up to get some sustenance
al-jazeera filmed these refugees and
better russian troops in the brewski
area near the polish border
belarus has in recent days stepped up
attempts to show its treating people
humanely on tuesday night it provided
shelter for hundreds of men women and
children in this warehouse
the commentary on this video comes from
brother russian state media
many of them have now returned to the
forest
these pictures from wednesday filmed by
poland's interior ministry apparently
show migrants leaving the makeshift camp
as better russian forces look on
some are carrying lugs the only thing
that's kept them warm at night
overnight there were fresh attempts to
break through the razor wire and reach
polish territory
hours earlier polish forces had used
water cannon across the border at a
group of migrants
polish border forces said they were
attacked with stones
polish police said one officer was taken
to hospital with a head injury
on the polish side what provision there
is has come from volunteers
on tuesday the human rights commissioner
of the council of europe visited one
migrant aid center near the border it is
absolutely unacceptable what belarus is
doing
and how the people are manipulated but
at the same time i think we need to
step aside and and think you know what
is happening at the european border why
are these people left in limbo and what
can be done in order to stop this
extremely dangerous situation
meanwhile polish forces of parked water
cannon opposite a new makeshift camp at
the border
with no sign the political standoff or
the misery for thousands stuck here
ending soon assad beg al-jazeera
uh
poland
jonah hull now in kuznetsov which is on
poland's side of the border with belarus
jonah has anything changed for those you
know 2 000 or so people stuck at the
border
well much as i said alluded to there
it's been another long hard miserable
day for those people and remember up to
half of them are women and children uh
several hundred would have made their
way this evening to that converted
warehouse
hastily converted only given to them on
tuesday by the belarusian authorities
it'll be pretty cold in there as well
with some minimal sort of bedding and
food laid on uh most of the rest have
headed off back to the camp in the
forest that has been their home for the
last
two weeks or so and there's really
nowhere else for them to go
they can't go forward into the european
union which which is what they most want
to do and what they came here to do as
they look out across sort of rolls of
barbed wire all they see is a bristling
force of polish
riot police and border guards who are
quite willing to use force to keep them
back and they did so on tuesday they
can't stay indefinitely in belarus
either they wouldn't want to and nor
frankly would the belarusians want them
to they are pawns in a game what we
don't know is quite how this game ends
there are diplomatic contacts open
between the eu and belarus a phone call
between angela merkel and alexander
lukashenko took place on tuesday and
there are some suggestions that those
contacts may be expanded in the days
um
to come
and beyond that you know it is a bit of
a waiting game for these people they
have nowhere to go they're not wanted on
either side alexander lukashenko has
said he will retaliate further if
sanctions go ahead those are still being
planned as we understand it and indeed
on wednesday news has come that
an oil pipeline or at least a branch of
an oil pipeline heading to the eu
through belarusian soil has been shut
off ostensibly for
maintenance purposes you can make your
own mind up about that and in the midst
of all of that of course there's a
rather dangerous looking wider
geopolitical context with russia at
least tacitly supporting what is going
on here uh behind its ally belarus while
at the same time mr putin preparing
potentially to open a new front against
another uh weakness of the european
union not in the eu perhaps but the
eastern border of ukraine with a big
russian military build-up happening
there
joanna at the risk of
stating the obvious here that the
humanitarian consequences of what's
going on here must be immense
well you know one can only hope that
these numbers don't grow that the
efforts that have been put in place to
try and sanction or threaten the
sanctions sanction the airlines that
have been bringing these people in at
belarus's behest are no longer doing so
and that at least the consequences can
be contained to the numbers of people
that are there now as awful as the
situation is for them 12 people have
died so far at least most of them from
exposure un agencies have warned that
could uh that number could rise as the
temperature plummets here the european
union says it's made seven hundred
thousand euros around a million dollars
available to pay for basic supplies
although it's not clear how those
suppliers will reach them but ursula
fond de la and the european commission
president said they stand ready to do
more as long as mr lukashenko stops
luring people here and putting lives
at risk so yeah it's all pretty nasty
frankly and as assad said there it isn't
clear
what the way out of all this may be
joe nahal reporting from the poland
belarus border thank you jonah